[Music]
let's do this
[Music]
guinea pig huh it's the rolls-royce of
rodents yeah but it's still a roadmap
you know what i mean
don't mind us just robbing this place
[Music]
go bad or go home
hey you get over here
a little bit closer
oh i know what it is
you're afraid because i'm the big bad
wolf
well i'm not surprised i am the villain
in every story and that right mr snake
say hello to mr snake
serpentine safe cracking machine imagine
houdini but with no arms kind of guy
who'd tell you the glass is half empty
then steal it from it he's also my best
bud today's his birthday not relevant
he's a sweetheart you're a sweetheart
well look who's here took him long
enough
[Music]
watch this
three
two
one
and over here is miss tarantula our
in-house hacker our pocket search engine
our traveling tech wizard we call her
webs
very slick webb i also took over the
police dispatch blurred their satellite
imaging system grounded their chopper
and one more thing
i got a special delivery for ah
happy birthday mr grumpy pants i think i
hate you
[Music]
[Applause]
guy it's me i was the construction
worker and this is mr shark master of
disguise
apex predator of a thousand faces
his greatest trick stealing the mona
lisa disguised as the mona lisa
dig that watch it big tuna i'm trying to
work here keep it cool baby birthday
should be chill
and rounding out the crew
surprise
is mr piranha
he's a loose cannon with a short fuse
willing to scrap with anyone or anything
he's brave
he's fearless
uh who am i kidding he's crazy
uh piranha did we forget something what
the present you know oh um
of course i didn't forget
you know you fart when you lie right
what no i thought when i'm nervous yeah
nervous about lying
i'm sorry
i breathed it in
yeah they're a bit eccentric but when
you're born us you don't exactly win
many popularity contests
do i wish people didn't see us as
monsters eight legs of cardio
sure what's up papa but these are the
cards we've been dealt so we might as
well play him jackpot
[Music]
[Music]
um
are you crazy what i just wanted a
longer car chase it's the best part
it's
them
webs hit it
[Music]
[Music]
let me know
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm gonna put you guys away for so long
your fleas will have fleas
you want some cake you seem a little
hangry
wrap that thing out of my face before
what
[Music]
[Applause]
you're mine
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
we may be bad but we're so good at it
[Music]
you